they want to go out and they want to
touch they want to vote
i'm working my ass off here i'm soaking
wet already
suppression balls
[Music]
yesterday we had three big ones really
big
suppression balls you don't give me the
umbrella i'm soaking wet already
they put numbers you know they're called
suppression suppression balls
they make you like feel badly so you say
to your wife you said your husband
darling let's go out to dinner and then
we'll come back we love our president
but you know the polls say he can't win
well right now we're leading
in almost everywhere
[Music]
suppression balls
suppression balls the name of jesus from
south america
they're coming here they're coming here
they're coming here they're coming here
from africa
i hear the sound of victory
[Music]
i hear the sound of victory i hear the
sound of victory
i hear the sound of winning winning
winning
[Music]
winning winning
all right guys normally we have tons of
time for nonsense on the show but today
we
we really don't so i'm gonna have to cut
that a little bit short
uh welcome everybody we're waiting for
in the absence of donald trump who is
just
missing donald trump has not taken a
single question from the press
for i don't even know how long it's been
i mean he did
the night of the election he came out
and said he won
and then on thursday the fifth he did a
press conference
took no questions and said he won and
then
last friday i believe it was
he came out and bragged about vaccines
and didn't take any questions so
i think it's been at least two and a
half weeks if not
um if not three
i i don't i don't know i don't remember
the last time trump took questions from
the press but
he's certainly not going to be doing it
today is the point but we are standing
by for a house republican leadership
press conference scheduled for 14
minutes from now
presumably one of the questions if it is
a real press conference rather than a
rant
presumably one of the questions that
they will be asked at the top of the
hour
is um do you believe
donald trump is going to be inaugurated
for a second term
um or don't you that i think would be a
very important question to ask
republican leadership at the top of the
hour uh for people saying chuck grassley
won't be there remember this is the
house
leadership chuck grassley is in the
senate so chuck grassley will not be
there
because he is not in the house um very
very important
element factual element to
uh remember a couple of super chats i
wanted to get to and i i just have so
much stuff for you guys that i'm i'm
glad we have time
chakuseki said giuliani arguing in front
of the pennsylvania federal courthouse
might be the funniest thing ever his
courtroom sketch probably looks like
batboy on mescaline
yeah i don't know if you guys heard but
you know how rudy giuliani is a tv
lawyer he's not really trump's lawyer
and that he's not arguing motions before
a court
rudy giuliani announced i think it was
yesterday or maybe today
that he would actually be representing
donald trump before
some pennsylvania court which i can't
even
imagine and i don't imagine it will be
televised it would be great if it was
but i do have for us a new interview
that rudy giuliani gave this was today
claiming he now has two vehicles ready
to go to the supreme court reportedly
both are diesel-powered um no i think
what he's saying here is he has two
paths to the supreme court via a chain
of subsequent
appeals and we're gonna look at that a
little bit later and rudy giuliani
um you know it's so funny that earlier
today on the bonus show i think it was
maybe it was on the broadcast show i
said
um who's paying for these attorneys
and how much are we paying them because
this entire voter fraud
thing and cases and lawsuits and all
this stuff it seems ripe for attorneys
billing a thousand dollars an hour
and then we learned rudy giuliani has
asked for it's not
i don't know whether he's gotten it but
rudy giuliani has asked for
twenty thousand dollars a day uh to
to do whatever it is that he is doing
including i guess
uh tucking in his pants as we saw in the
borat film
junk saint wants to know via super chat
how to respond to specific comments to
make names highlight
i have no idea i've never left a youtube
comment that i can remember
ever so that's not some but i'm sure
someone can tell you
uh ryan says i spent two dollars to say
donald j
trump is more punctual than you that's
very much untrue
sam says oh my god david i had to flush
my toilet nine times today i've been
told the plumbing is old and can be iffy
but i know deep down it's because of
these do-nothing democrats yeah remember
donald trump for a while explained to us
if joe biden is elected there will be
more no more air conditioning or heating
in the winter
there will be no water pressure
dishwashers you'll have to run them two
or three times to get your dishes clean
and you'll have to flush your toilet 10
to 15 times so
i'm still waiting for that just to be
sure
i've started flushing 15 times because i
don't want to get caught in a weird
situation
but i don't know that you have to flush
15 times yet it must be coming soon
but not yet ryan also spent another
dollar
two dollars to say i'm cool okay very
good
um hey love the show was hoping you
could touch on the lack of orange and
blonde on trump in his address the other
day
yeah trump it almost seemed like he
allowed his hair to go white again
i don't know serge says it's bizarre
watching biden speak he's coherent
doesn't insult or attack anyone tells no
lies and makes references to doctors and
science
it is jarring yeah joe raider says new
entry into the s p 500 coming very
powerfully on december
21st i assume you mean tesla
um yeah tesla i still own my tesla stock
let's pull it up it was announced that
tesla
would be entering the s p 500
i'm still holding um i bought in 2015.
so let's see where we are uh the
this is this split i think there was a
four to one split
um let me see here when did i buy i
believe i bought in february of 2015
at it says 40 and i think it split four
to one
which would have made it 160 or did it
split five to one does anybody remember
the hell i don't even know what's going
on anyway i panic sold half
my stock around here when
um the elon musk on joe rogan panic set
in and i was like oh my god it's going
down
and of course i was wrong this is why i
i don't tell anybody to follow my
stock picks because i don't know what
the hell is going on
but that uh that's what's going on guys
okay so i don't know anything else about
it
all right um let me get back to this
super chat in a little bit okay a few
things for you guys
i have memes and i have voicemails which
do you want first
memes or voicemails it was a five to one
split thank you
i appreciate being told that memes and
voicemails
memes and voicemails
people seem to want the memes first okay
fine so i've got a couple different
things um
one is let me do these one by one so the
other day
oh i wish i was more organized today
hold on a second
there we go so the other day i posted
what may be
my last appearance at a cafe
uh for the entire season to my instagram
david.pacman you should really be
following me on instagram if you're not
this was instantly memed
with me wearing a biden harris
hat i had a coffee with extra plasma
as you can see i have the laptop from
hell in front of me as you can see
property of hunter biden and then this
is that remember how um tucker carlson
sent those documents
and they were lost in the mail it was
sort of like the dog ate the homework
i actually as you can see here have a
ups envelope right in front of me is
that ups
i guess it is attention tucker carlson
in la so this was the scene as you can
imagine
and the extra plasma on the coffee very
very important
uh oh okay i have the producer pat fraud
video we'll get to that
this one i played for i showed you last
week if you uh saw
in the corner at the paula white event
i was there i was the guy walking around
in the background this gentleman a
little more portly than i am but he does
have the nikes which i will sometimes
wear
and then also this is a nice touch the
clorox clorox bleach
which you need you definitely need to
fight off the virus
um this one was posted by
action adam to my subreddit david i
would just like to say we here in paris
are very worried about trump refusing to
concede
yes it's very sad so are croissants
still a thing over there i guess this is
sort of making a joke out of when i get
international callers
i'll ask them food questions to sort of
lighten the mood
i i think that the the audience enjoys
that correct me if i'm wrong
uh but i would i would love to be back
in paris as i was here
sipping a cappuccino and uh oh there
they don't call it cappuccino though
they call it something else
and having a croissant and then i don't
know if you guys saw me
this is my this is my strategy to lure
donald trump out of the white house we
know how much he loves kfc
um so i this i'm gonna show up with a
fishing pole
and see if i can get trump to leave this
way i think it's
completely plausible that it would uh
that it would work all right very good
so strong
meme submissions today i very very much
appreciate that
okay let me do a cup i'll do a couple of
voicemails
we got two voicemails we got one
voicemail from
the guy who calls me dave david prickles
and then we got another one from troy
york using another
bizarre pseudonym let's go i don't know
which is which i'll just play the first
one and we'll take a listen to it
here we go this could be anything get
the kids out of the room
hi david this is wally jackson
um giving you a call i do have a
question i noticed that you
retweet aaron ruber uh the reporter a
lot and um
i'm just wondering if like him and
people like you
and daniel dale if um i don't know who
daniel dale is first of all
if you guys are disgruntled because um
there's really not many gay bars anymore
[Laughter]
first of all i don't know is that i mean
are bars even a thing during the virus
but aaron aaron rupar is
married to a woman and has a baby so
he's not a gay guy
i'm not a gay guy i don't mind gay bars
but i wouldn't be disgruntled by their
presence or absence um
i've always been amazed i'm going to
write this on my blog about how few
homosexual bars there are um see that's
it's weird that that's something troy
york is even
keyed into like i who's thinking about
gay bars all the time and the number of
gay bars
for a people who have such influence
political influence and power in urban
areas
i'm amazed how like there's so few bars
um gay bars in uh
uh large cities okay so clearly a very
very important issue top of mind for
troy york
i i actually wonder i mean to take it
seriously
if we had sort of like full
acceptance of lgbt folks
you you almost like wouldn't need
separate gay bars anymore because
lgbt folks would just go to bars and it
would be fine
i think that the the existence of gay
bars seems to have been
predicated on the idea that you you know
there was um
there was a desire for a place where
people could just be who they are
without
you know risking running into people
like troy york i guess is the point i'm
making
okay and then lastly um
oh somebody's telling me i follow daniel
dale that's fine that maybe i don't know
him by name i follow
you know a bunch of people on twitter
here's a last one this is david prickles
guy
hey [ __ ] we're gonna bomb the [ __ ]
out of iran
what did you do lick your mother's
clitoris and
stick your tongue up her
is he saying her china that's really
weird your wings around a little bit
more maybe you'll fly back to
venezuela i've never been to venezuela
you
call me not a communist either you're an
[ __ ]
all of these are all yous are
can you believe that accent
stephanie can kick your ass stephanie is
that's a non-sequitur i assume he
stephanie can kick my ass um
i assume he's referring to stephanie
miller yeah i mean listen i would not
mess with stephanie miller
i think he's there if there's anything
accurate in that voicemail it's that
stephanie miller
probably can kick my ass that's true
that's very very true
stephanie um yeah that guy
something's very very wrong with that
guy that's that's absolutely for sure
okay we've gotten that out of the way
let's
continue i want to get to some of your
super chats and twitch messages before i
do that i do want to say thanks to patti
deroy who just signed up on my website
and peter van wick signed up on my
website their new members
one and two today at joinpakman.com
we do have this hot new coupon code
fresh start
because why because
it's a fresh start with joe biden we're
also
counting twitch subs towards our goal we
are at 24.88 that's
10 new ones my friends which puts us at
12. consider yourselves invited grab a
subscription at joinpacman.com it is
actually the number one funding source
for the show some of you may have heard
that we lost all monetization on
facebook last week
because i talked about steve bannon
saying fauci should be beheaded
bannon was not banned from facebook for
saying it
i was demonetized on facebook for saying
hey you know what it's bad to be head
people and it's bad to call for violence
we were demonetized so in any case grab
a membership
at joinpakman.com always very much
appreciated the coupon code
perfect coupon code saves you 70
and i guess that reminds me i promised
you
the producer pat ford video so i played
this last week but it has
replay value as many of you know donald
trump launched a voter fraud line where
you could call and report
fraud if you saw it and they had to shut
it down because they
they got too many phony phone calls but
before it happened producer pat ford was
able to call in
and report me for my borderline illegal
deals as well as voting three times in
vegas under the name david parkman
let me get this set up here uh hold on a
second
let's see if i can get this going for
you whoa hold on a second that's the
wrong thing
uh here it is i should have had this
prepared
i apologize that i didn't but we do have
it
shrink it a little bit more
there we go okay listen to this this is
this is genius
hello yes i would like to report voter
fraud today
sure what's your experience by the way
the woman
sounds defeated like she's just been
taking prank calls all day let's
continue
um well there's a certain david parkman
who i know uh to have voted
in nevada um three times at least
okay and what county is that in clark
county
he goes there uh twice a year for a um
conference that's true i do tend to go
there
and also he happens to be giving out um
borderline illegal membership discounts
uh like 50 off 60 off 70 off
and i'm worried that that could be
sacrificing the integrity of the
election
okay and what was your name my name is
oh now it actually got difficult he
hadn't planned for this mcdonald
mcdonald it's like madonna it's just a
single it just it just it's it's you
know
it does there's no need for a last name
it's just mcdonald that's it
and uh quite quite plain and simple
nothing nothing to be shy about there
so that was it and as you guys know now
that we've been outed
it's it's only a matter of time until
these um
illegal membership discounts have to go
away so take advantage of it take
advantage of it while you can
okay let me say hello to a few other
people
moon dog subscribed with twitch prime
and says 11
very powerful months i appreciate that
thank you
11 months um i guess that's it chaotic
stasis said what's up everybody
so that chaotic checking in as well
appreciate that
let me get to a few other super chats
and see what's on people's minds
edwin says worst case scenario what
should happen for trump to get his
second term of course we the same people
of the world hope it won't get to that
tr trump lost guys trump lost boom
that's it
trump lost biden's president-elect
brendan says hey david according to
socialblade your youtube channel
is rated as an a-minus and dave rubin's
is
only rated as a b-plus keep churning
those ideas
oh i had a dave rubin thing um
i don't know if we really want to do
this
but uh hold on a second meltdown
uh i have a very interesting video
i just need to this i definitely was not
prepared for oh i see what's going on
hold on
ruben meltdown
oh man i'm having trouble finding it
here where where is this thing
uh flagged
oh i can't believe this what day is it
17th
this was yesterday uh i can't find it
anyway there's this amazing video
oh wait a second wait a second i know
where it is i know where it is here it
is
there's this incredible video of the
slow evolution of okay people want to
see it
this is really really funny this is the
um
evolution of dave rubin going from
like pre-election to post election i'm
not going to do the whole thing because
it's 11 minutes but so so
here's the the gist let's listen to just
a little bit of dave rubin's rhetoric
about this election this is before
before election day okay so there's
there's no way they're going to accept
the election this time and i do think
trump's gonna win most likely in a
landslide trump is gonna win
and he's gonna win in a bigger way than
he won last time sounds crazy but
trump's gonna get 30
of the black vote and they know it and
that's why they're freaking out i
tweeted about a year ago that tru
that trump's gonna get 30 of the black
vote okay so that was pre-election all
right
then we go to now this is election day
okay take a listen to this this was on
november 3rd
dave rubin is out in uh los angeles
what is it like in california today
friend you see this yeah i do this is a
big smile glenn
we're gonna be okay glenn everything's
gonna be okay
but looking it's looking good but glenn
i gotta show you something
i got a prop my friend and could you
imagine only four years later
a man would have are you putting it on
these are you gotta put it out looking
really good tonight
okay yeah it's all happening it's all
happening
i could probably end the live stream
right there because it's all happening
it's looking good
it ain't over yet but yes there are a
lot of people in full meltdown mode
uh on the left there's a lot of people
rejoicing on the right
but i think everybody watching this at
least can take a deep breath
the american experiment is going to
continue
tonight is an absolute pushback
on the bf anyway okay so then it got to
november 4th
and then um you know it started to not
look quite so good seemed to have
stopped in all of these places i didn't
know that that was a thing suddenly
people had to go home they couldn't
count votes anymore this is
the most important election of a
generation of a lifetime ever
people got to take naps also um it all
got very bizarre that it seemed to all
happen
it was really weird exactly what was
predicted happened wow which is like you
know a lot of those mailing ballots were
for biden wow shocking
at the exact same time most likely the
machinery in those states
probably won't buy it and to win right
that the machinery
that's exactly what i was talking about
with glenn beck on monday
right that a conspiracy isn't just
you know it's not just the the evil guys
and the simpsons laughing in the room
you know it's not just
that but that it sort of moves and
morphs and kind of happens in
real time and suddenly as they it seems
that
okay so so he's just going on and on
let's go to one a little bit later this
is like
later in the week november 5th
application was received
on september 11 2020 and
uh the ballot was sent on 9 19 2020
and it was received he's now reading
ballot applications guys
uh 12 days later on 10 to 20 20. so
congratulations
to 118 year old dead william bradley
from wayne county detroit uh you voted
your family must be very passionate you
see why this is a problem guys like i i
don't mean to be silly about this stuff
oh this should be good i haven't seen
this last part
[Music]
the end is near i'll say yeah that no
matter what happens
right now i know that i did what i
thought was right
like i really did i did what i thought
was right as i said yesterday it's come
at a cost
personally uh through friends and family
and a whole bunch of other stuff
i have no doubt that if trump loses like
there's gonna be all sorts of people
that will try to destroy all of the
people that had anything to do with
trump
like me is i think what he's saying is
like me people will know
i will be punished for the grift
anything like that um
but i'm i'm really proud that i stood up
and
said what i believe which is why when i
through the comment section here i know
that you guys in
in some cases like i'm a pro guys this
is it's performance art
it's it's some kind of avant-garde
performance art i don't know how else to
describe it
um but it is we it's
you know sociologists uh should be
looking at that
for decades to come because that that is
like nothing i have ever seen it's
really crazy
now the other i don't want to get too
much into this but just one last thought
on ruben
i talked to some um friends the other
day
who like me know dave rubin even though
you know he he doesn't talk to any of us
anymore
they felt very strongly that all of this
is
bs that dave rubin didn't really have a
political awakening
he had a financial awakening and he
realized like hey i can make money
opening for jordan peterson and uh
you know meeting trump and being friends
with don jr and they feel
this is just that assertion i'm not
saying that that i know this to be true
but that reuben is still the the
progressive guy
that he was seven years ago or whenever
and that this is all just a character
for money
which uh which which is interesting and
what what also is really
wild anyway to get back to the very
beginning as people pointed out
um the reuben report youtube channel is
is not even doing that well like i
wonder what
is this even that profitable like when
you look at actual views
i don't want to pull this up on screen
um necessarily
but when you look at views let me see
how it compares to us
reuben report like is it even that
profitable
from the standpoint of views
we get 1.6 million views a day and
reuben gets 383
000 so like with all this grift
he only gets 25 of the views that we get
which is so i'm like is it even really
that profitable for him to have done
i don't know i really don't know but uh
it is what it is as donald trump once
said okay very good
let me thank a couple of other people
ali hamrang
is new member number 13 on my website
today also want to say thanks to robert
williams who's new member number 14.
christian zintel is new member number
15. louis lucas is 16
and scott walsh is number 17 also
including uh obviously i mean listen i'm
not
i'm not this i'm not gonna attack
anybody we're including our twitch subs
as well
and there are eight more there putting
us at 25
and uh yeah i'm willing to open the
phone lines for sure if we hit
our uh if we hit our goal very very much
willing to do that
all right let me get so let me just
start closing things out here
so we did we did the twitter thing we
did the reuben thing
oh okay let's let's just briefly look at
a little bit of this giuliani interview
um before it's kind of weird that this
event is running late kind of bizarre
uh 10 minutes late all right we'll keep
an eye on it here's a giuliani interview
this is him explaining how he has two
vehicles ready to go to the supreme
court
election fraud officials in georgia's
floyd county discovering more than
2600 ballots netting nearly 800
additional votes
i haven't seen this yet in the peach
state the problem reportedly due to
election officials neglecting to upload
a memory card
from a ballot scanning machine this
company rejects an appeal to void their
election election
their election results ahead of today's
expected certification
the trump campaign faces a hearing this
afternoon in pennsylvania
they allege voters were held to a
different standard depending on if they
voted by mail or in person
joining me right now is the former mayor
of new york city personal attorney for
president trump
rudy giuliani rudy it's great to see you
once again this morning thank you so
much for being with me
by the way guys what the hell happened
to maria bartiromo
when i was 16 17 and got into trading
stocks
which i don't do anymore other than you
know like the eight or ten stocks i have
but i'm mostly a mutual fund guy
um she was actually sort of like
breaking new ground
she was the first woman reporting from
the floor of the new york stock exchange
he was
doing hard actual hard-hitting
interviews with ceos
and it if she had like an interesting
thing going now she's just a trump
suck-up it's sad
very nice to be with you maria uh yes
we're going to argue the case
uh-oh we've got a delay today go ahead
yep tell me about that i've said we're
gonna arg we're gonna get the case in
pennsylvania today it's really a
preliminary
motion it's a motion to dismiss the case
on technical
legal grounds uh that case is a case
that
you know it's connected to the other
eight or nine and the case shows
uh and we're prepared to call witnesses
to demonstrate that
somewhere around 700 000 ballots
were counted surreptitiously they were
counted in secret
the republican uh the republican uh
watchers which is what they're called in
pennsylvania
were literally kept in in corrals this
is known to be untrue yeah they were
corralled like heifers
then locked out some of them were
actually roughed up a little bit
roughed up in the philadelphia part not
the pittsburgh part
but the total number now is i mean the
exact number is 688 thousand seven
hundred and seventy
uh i thought it was 771. i thought it
was 688 0771.
700 000 by the time we finished the
hearing that'll be on thursday
but today is to really argue argue the
legal part of the case
and and frankly imagine being a judge
and all of a sudden giuliani is in front
of you arguing a motion
there's a case that we would like to see
get to the supreme court
so you know we're prepared in some of
these cases to lose
and to appeal it's good that they're
prepared to lose i think that's the
smartest thing he's said so far
and to get at the supreme court you
might remember in bush v gore
it was the it was uh the bush campaign
lost
in the state of florida because it was a
democratic court five
two if i recall correctly right uh so
you're not you're not going to win every
one of these
i don't want to say it's because it's a
democrat judge or whatever right
he would never say that anybody that it
would be unfair to say that
but in some cases you win some cases you
lose
most important thing is this is our this
will be now our first established
vehicle on our way to the supreme court
right
i should say exactly a second the one in
michigan
even though the the certification by the
way look it went ahead
the look on maria bartoros
have you guys noticed that every time
one either
a trump campaign person or a so-called
whistleblower appears on tv
to explain the fraud this is the look
you see on everybody's face as they're
explaining
even people friendly to all of this that
case is
also another vehicle to go to the
supreme court so now we have two
uh shortly we'll have wisconsin and soon
georgia
does anybody for a second think that
they are going to get
four cases to the supreme court in the
next 10 weeks
do you cons at its face it's ridiculous
three more right after that the ones i
just mentioned to you
already drafted and ready to go and and
what are you finding so far what do you
think went on here because when we spoke
on sunday we talked about the software
made by smartmatic that was changing
votes from trump
to biden
yeah but the core of the case yeah let's
call it the meat of the case
and the one that's common really in 10
cities
the tenderloin of the case so to speak
probably going to assume at least eight
or nine of them
is that they stopped republican watchers
inspectors observers they have different
names in different states
to perform the absolutely vital function
of observing
the opening of the mail ballot uh
if you don't observe the opening of the
mail ballot it is lost forever because
the only thing that identifies it is a
signature on the outer envelope
when you certify that signature you
separate the
outer envelope from the ballot the
ballot's anonymous
so even if we go back and we find the
some of the signatures that are wrong or
phony ones or whatever
understand what they've come up with
they've actually it's almost genius what
they've come up with because
if this is their story and as rudy says
you can't ever
undo that the only way
really is to do a new election right
because what once you've
separated the inner on and i did this
when i voted absentee in massachusetts
when you
separate the inner envelope from the
outer envelope and let me just keep an
eye on this press conference just to see
okay it still hasn't started
when you separate the inner envelope if
you can't undo that you don't actually
know
like you you don't even know how many
ballots
need to be reconnected and thus the only
like if if we grant them that this is
what took place
the only real way is you throw out every
single ballot in pennsylvania and you
start over like i don't even understand
another way that that you could
you could uh remedy that of course
there's no evidence that they've
presented that what they're alleging
took place
let's just listen to just a tiny bit
more i won't be able to link it to a
ballot
so the only remedy the court has is to
just cancel out those votes which
they've done in pennsylvania
in the in the uh the ross case
so pennsylvania has in fact uh reversed
an election
based on absentee irregularities there's
no there's no bigger absentee
irregularity
than failure to observe the bout now
what's really important to understand is
rudy is talking about 700 000 ballots
right and when you hear about 700
000 and you go and you look at the
results you say wait a second
so the margin in pennsylvania is now
what is that 38 and 35 that's about 73
72 900 ballots roughly it looks like
700 000 ballots that would easily
overturn
a margin of 72 000 because 700 000 is
roughly 10 times bigger okay good but
when you look at what's
actually been placed before a court
they're talking about here we go now
tranches
of like 40 000 ballots some
fraction of which would be for one
candidate
and some fraction of which would be for
the other candidate so it
just to do some quick math let me see if
i can do this imagine that you have
just to make the numbers simple let's
imagine you identified a tranche of 50
000 ballots right
which went uh 60 40
for biden so of this 50 000 ballot
tranche you had 30k biden
and 20k trump so in this 50
000 vote tranche biden was plus 10k
imagine that you go through all 40 000
of them
and they were way off it was really 60
40 trump
okay all that does is move
10 000 ballots like even if you were
way off on that tranche it doesn't even
come close
to reversing the results and this is
where people are getting bamboozled and
why
you know they have these interviews
where even fox news uh hosts
start getting agitated uh with the trump
people who don't seem to explain like
what is your path to actually winning
because you don't
you've not even presented a path to
overturning one state
never mind overturning multiple states
which you would need to do at this point
so
this will go away soon i presume that by
december
you guys tell me if you disagree i
presume that by december 14th
um this will all be gone right i mean
there trump will be in at mar-a-lago
and um there i mean how once it's
certified it's over i would imagine can
anybody confirm that what do you guys
think
it's t-r-a-n-c-h-e by the way people
wondering about
tranche dear god
okay very good let me get to let me get
back to a few other super chats as we as
we stand by here zachary foster says
glad the biden team is good at science
communication not only striking
down those who underplay coveted but
also the fear mongers
ryan nowicki says if the blue wave
continues will progressives be able to
beat the democratic party flooding the
field and
grouping to beat someone like bernie
similar to 2020.
beat someone like bernie i ryan i apolo
i'm not sure i know what you're asking
flooding the field and grouping oh oh i
understand
it depends on whether the blue wave is
an establishment democratic or a more
progressive wave
i think that's the uh i think that's the
gist of it huge
thank you to cornelia fenwinkel
who has gifted five subscriptions on
twitch
putting us now at 2501
and in total putting us at
30 for the day also want to say
thanks to a few other people who signed
up on my website
one two three four five six seven eight
eight more putting us at uh
at 38 in total and yes phone lines phone
lines will open right now we're standing
by for the house leadership conference
um other super chats coming in let me
see here
whoa i missed a bunch here let me see
where was that ryan nowicki was the last
one
wait a second then here we go ah there
we go
with the rise in the far-right violence
how dead is gun control
liberal gun owners how dead is gun
control liberal gun owners
uh i i don't know i'd have to think
about that
rudy giuliani should be disbarred
i propose we rename the process of
filing multiple flimsy lawsuits to make
it seem plausible that there's something
happening is taking someone on a trump
trip
much like a gish gallop not a bad idea
alex says would producer pat be willing
to box don jr if don jr requested a
match
i think he would pat's been doing you
know various elements of mixed martial
arts and i think that pat would totally
go for that
we can check tomorrow you should
collaborate with matt dillahunty over
chess and with
varsh over anything so i've got a full
interview with vosh on my youtube
channel you can
find i've interviewed matt dillahunty
before i actually had a phone call
perfect phone call
with matt dillahunty the other day
wendy says 20 grand a day for a washed
up lawyer like rudy the story becomes
stranger and stranger
in regards to 70 million trump voters
can trump endorsement have a king maker
effect
i think we need to wait to see how much
political capital donald trump maintains
after he leaves office i don't know uh i
don't know the answer to that yet
it's unclear my republican family says
biden will be impeached should i be
worried
god not not yet no i wouldn't worry for
now um
by the way with a democratic house
remember that before the senate can vote
on whether to convict
on impeachment the democratic house
needs to actually
vote to impeach it seems unlikely seems
unlikely tristan said comments under
biden's speech today were trumpists
laughing at biden because biden thinks
he's president-elect we are in trouble
well what is the cognitive dissonance
going to be when biden is inaugurated
what are the trumpists going to say
just it was stolen it was stolen it was
stolen that's it
do you expect the republican party to
start breaking from trump soon on the
election messaging
i think that you'll see a break to some
degree after the election is certified
on december 14th
chakaseki says can we officially put
scott atlas in radiology jail
for his incendiary and dangerous
comments i think we can use a pair of
lead handcuffs
yeah i'm going to have a report tomorrow
about scott atlas actually and i'm going
to have to preface the report by saying
none of this is um none of this is an
attack on radiology
okay none of it is an attack on
radiology waffle says when are you
hiring jenk yeuger
very soon oh very very soon he's going
to be working for me
tesla reminds me did you see open ai
gpt-3
no i have no idea what that is how far
back has 45
set us in civil rights and women's
rights
four to eight years all right i would
say dan wondering if we're in a skit
did i watch zuckerberg and dorsey
testify today i watched 10 minutes of it
that's all pebble says any thoughts on
trump opening
bidding for oil in alaska highly
disappointed
disgusting absolutely disgusting listen
we'll be lucky if trump doesn't bomb
anybody on the way out
that's where i would where i would put
it charles says are you going to get
into foreign policy issues this week
like russia iran and north korea we
dealt with iran actually
very powerfully on today's show ali says
watching from europe
as american tv is good at the moment
loving the trump voter fraud
tv series yeah me too it's pretty
dystopian though
ms smith says have you any thoughts on
the lindsey graham georgia secretary of
state throwing out ballots
yes i'm going to talk about that
extensively tomorrow
lindsey graham now is being accused by
two people
of suggesting to the georgia secretary
of state that they just throw ballots
out like just throw them in just don't
count them
find identify ballots that leaned biden
groups of ballots tranches of ballots
and just throw them into the trash if
that's not a crime for a senator to
suggest
uh well then i mean i don't know is it a
crime i'm not sure that's part of what
we will discuss
tomorrow wendy says daniel dale is a
fact checker
he appears on cnn very good i haven't
watched cable news
in a very very long time other than
clips i get for the show
brody andrew mullikin mulligan says
david
some of us in the lgbtqia plus community
want a gay bar because as you said it is
a place where we can feel safe love from
dallas stay safe yeah
like i said uh the lack of a need for
gay bars
would show progress but of course the
voicemail from troy york
was uh laughable and and ridiculous for
sure
let me head on over to twitch because i
do have a bunch of people sending me
messages
nick lovin has subscribed and says this
is kind of out of left field
a sandwich is a food typically
consisting of vegetables
sliced cheese or meat placed on or
between
slices of bread or more generally any
dish
wherein bread serves as a container or
wrapper for another food type well you
know
a twinkie by that definition may be a
sandwich because it you you basically
have a
fl i mean flour makes it bread maybe you
would consider it pastry but
you are wrapping uh you are wrapping
cream in bread essentially
a twinkie would be a sandwich by this
ridiculous definition
okay pawn broken broken says david had
to sell my plasma
but it's worth it for the membership and
then crimson elrick says hey doing great
you should try to get nicholas crostakis
on the show
he has a new book called apollo's arrow
discussing kovid's impact yeah we have
an invitation out to him actually
uh to nicolas christakis i would love to
have him on i am unsure
whether whoa what the hell just happened
we just lost this stream i guess now
we're waiting on one other stream that's
bizarre
okay i guess we're waiting
um is a calzone a sandwich or pizza
holy that's tough is a calzone a
sandwich or a p
i i think a calzone is an italian
empanada
actually is the way i would put it um
yeah i feel pretty good about that
calzone is more of a ravioli than a
sandwich actually right i mean that's
that's not
totally untrue i'd have to think about a
calzone
crazy cat lady with a very strong
message david pakman you were so sexy
here's five bucks
beautiful message uh and kyle donating
five dollars for a new gay bar
brody also mentioning david be careful
your discount is not legal in texas
i believe that it is legal in harris
county
um but not not anywhere else okay
other super chat other memberships
coming in
we do have two more which i want to tack
on to 40.
um as we stand by for this press
conference i do want to mention in all
serious i know we joke around a lot
about you know illegal discounts and
that type of thing
uh i do want to invite you if you've
been appreciating the streams if you
like what we do
grab a membership at joinedpakman.com it
includes the commercial free
full show every day plus the bonus show
featuring producer pat
including his uh phony phone calls
and all of that sort of stuff and
it is really really cheap it's dirt
cheap it's almost offensive how cheap
these memberships are
and you can sign up at joinpakman.com
coupon code fresh start
for 70 off borderline illegal discount
certainly immoral if nothing else and i
invite you to grab such a membership
uh really does help the show very very
much so okay
um chakaseki says do you think they
brought up the demonetization of david
pakman show by facebook at the
congressional hearing today with
zuckerborg
no i wish they had i wish they had
that would have been interesting
courtney says hatred version of tom
waits what's he building right
why is everyone talking about freud
these days
he was a great philosopher but i'm not
sure what he has to do with the election
right that's
fraud fraud
ross says sorry they demonetized you
greetings from bulgaria
greetings and um
dino sacks has hey david donato from the
uk did you see the interview with greg
palast on status coup
i did not i should do a follow-up with
jessie lee now that we have biden as
president-elect
interesting and uh unknown prodigy
688 770 votes in daylights in cups of
coffee in
inches and miles how do you measure the
vote of a woman or man
seasons of love from rent i don't know
what language that even is
whose dementia is worth worse trumps or
giuliani's i'm going to opt out of that
i'm gonna opt out of that
and then uh whoa i lost a few
okay let me get back to super chats
momentarily
um because i do have a number of other
things that i want to go over
okay so i i'm calling it done with the
the giuliani interview
couple songs i did want to play for you
we have one i don't know if i got to
this one
this is by michael carlucci this is
another
uh paula white song take a listen to
this
smooth uh smooth low low energy though
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
will give us victory god i hear a sound
[Music]
you know it's windy as hell out here
yeah
this room it's so hot in here maybe i'll
start to believe it myself
[Music]
all right so that's michael carlucci we
also have
the new david pakman show theme song by
max music take a listen
this is really solid
beautiful
[Music]
here's something interesting today's
episode is sponsored by
[Music]
it's perfect we have so much to cover
today that i will not
waste any time
[Music]
okay so there's that and then um we do
have
uh paula white is winning this is a good
one
jesus from south america they're coming
here they're coming here
they're coming here they're coming here
from africa
i hear the sound of victory
[Music]
i hear the sound of victory i hear the
sound of victory
i hear the sound of winning winning
winning
[Music]
anyway so the music the music stuff is
pretty strong uh pretty strong right now
um is it true that this has been
cancelled
is that actually true because we've been
waiting for it for a while now
i'm being told it is true that this has
been canceled
wow that's weird why would they cancel
this event
trump fired everybody yeah that could be
all right well listen i guess we're not
going to get the event
let me at least take some phone calls
then let me hear from a few of you
um i i'm sorry i mean i'm i'm told that
it's been canceled which is insane
uh we were hoping to hear some
explanations from republican lawmakers
but i guess i guess we're not going to
get them
if you i invite i hope you'll stay if
you are heading out make sure to hit the
subscribe button on youtube
the follow button on twitch the like
button on facebook you'll be notified of
future streams
but um i i you know i have no control
over i guess i guess it's been canceled
so let me um
i'll take some phone calls on discord
davidpakman.com
discord hear from a few people
um but what i mean they just they're not
showing up
that's bizarre truly truly bizarre
um okay yeah let me get to a few so
davidpakman.com
discord get yourself into the waiting
lobby
and once there you will be able to
talk to me okay and make sure obviously
all proper
etiquette from the standpoint of um
listening in in uh discord rather than
on youtube or the stream because that'll
just cause problems i'll just hear from
a few people
um let's see here
let's go to wow
let's go to ivan from moscow this sound
we've never taken a phone call from
russia before
unless it's from moscow idaho
oh no no uh hello david can you hear me
yes i can
oh my god i'm so excited man me too
first of all i i would like to take a
moment to appreciate what you're doing
you're a great person and i really
admire your work
wow and thank you for the discord
channel because it's truly international
and it helps to
get to know uh people all around the
world
and it's it's really a beautiful thing
that you did it thank you very much
thank you and i appreciate your pristine
audio coming
in from russia yeah uh
thank you very much david mike my
question is that
uh now there is a situation where
when uh trump has escalated the
uh the relationship between
uh united the united states and china
yes now
uh he's accusing china of everything of
his he's calling coronavirus the china
virus
uh the whole thing with the huawei uh
the com
the uh uh smart the mobile
company which develops smartphones and
stuff i think you uh you're aware of
everything yes absolutely yeah so
what do you think uh will it be like
will biden change anything in terms of
policy towards
uh china or is it uh actually
uh good for him like the trump did
all the dirty work for him basically so
that's a good question i think biden is
going to undo the tariffs on china
you know it'll it'll have to be part of
a negotiation because china has reason
now to be skeptical of the united states
much like iran does because we just you
know
change what what trump comes in and just
does whatever the hell he wants with no
respect to what's been negotiated in the
past
but i do think that joe biden will get
to a point where the tariffs that
trump did on china will be removed
got it and and another question uh in
regards to russia
yeah so uh i remember that biden says uh
while he was debating with trump i think
he said
uh something like i know i know them and
they know me
something uh in that something like that
yes so what do you think what is going
to be his uh policy
uh his relationships to our country i
imagine that biden's relationship to
russia will be similar to barack obama's
which was
you know let's let's be perfectly frank
here uh ivan we've seen a bit of a uh
donald trump has not exactly been the
alpha male in the relationship with
putin it's really been putin who has
taken that role
i think that with barack obama and putin
it was certainly much more balanced if
not obama being the one who sort of
had had the upper hand so i think that
it will be treated more
um as a respectfully adversarial
relationship
among you know the three big superpowers
the u.s china and russia
you work together it's sort of like a
trust but verify
type of thing yes exactly i
i i agree with you actually tell me ivan
what is what is happening with the
sputnik vaccine have you gotten this
vaccine
uh no david i haven't heard of it uh
actually i mean i i wait hold up well
hold on it's like wait wait wait wait
wait wait
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa let's back
it up you you live in in russia right
in moscow yeah you're saying you haven't
heard about the fact that like over a
month ago russia has
has had a vaccine no no i mean i
i haven't heard that it is being uh
used now like i haven't heard that uh
it um i i don't know if you can
uh go and get your vaccination there is
a usual
seasonal flu vaccination that was uh uh
earlier uh in this autumn but i don't
think that this vaccine is
i can be mistaken though i mean uh i
don't know for sure if you can get it
wow because internationally
a huge propaganda deal was made by
russia that
you you have the vaccine and people are
getting it
no maybe some people are getting it but
i mean
it hasn't been made available to you
that you're aware of
yes david so i i cannot i mean i'm not a
politician i can
i can't make such claims that there is
no vaccine or right
you cannot have it but i mean i am
personally
not aware of the fact that i can get it
or somewhere who is not in some
i don't know special program uh so
uh fascinating fascinating and uh is it
true that you are uh
that that you're taught chess from an
early age in school in russia
i don't know it's uh so many stereotypes
really uh every time i join the discord
chat
it's really it sounds like uh people
people uh think of our country as it was
i don't know 20 maybe 30 or 40 years ago
even
so you're saying you were not you did
not learn chess
no i i learned chess you did oh so
you're like these stereotypes are crazy
why are do people yes i
actually did have chess class in school
yeah yeah
there were chess classes and uh
competitions but they're not compulsory
though no it wasn't mandatory right okay
good very good
ivan listen it's been a pleasure please
do call back
okay david i certainly will thank you
very much for taking my call
my pleasure what what a phone call guys
unbelievable
unbelievable um okay
let's go next to
um
i don't even understand is is this
someone named alexander from a place
named
crystal or someone named crystal from a
place named alexander
yeah you got it right i'm just kidding
no i'm from crystal my name is alex
what is crystal crystal's just a town
right near minneapolis
oh okay crystal mint crystal minnesota
you're from
right got it i live there so it's not
where i'm from but you know
good enough for me good enough for the
purposes of this call
sure so i have a you know i've got a
couple things david
uh first thing is you always uh tell
people to put a colon in their name
on a discord but uh you know i've tried
that like three times and it says
you can't put a call in your name so i
don't know these people who are doing it
be very skeptical how they did it seemed
like they're uh
hacking the system or something okay we
will look into that
right definitely should look into it
very strongly yeah um
the other thing is um you know what now
we're on this
discord system i'm curious do you uh
track
polar ratings or uh what's happened to
that system i want to have my rating
back i actually kind of demand it
okay um yeah we don't currently have a
caller rating system a lot of it just
you know i have copious notes but uh
that may be
a new feature that we could set up for
sure so far you'd be about a five and a
half so let's see if we can up
it right all right yeah it's unfortunate
i'm seeing everybody in chat saying i'm
a troll but i am the like
you know about to be on 17-month
subscriptions so you know
that there's actually i think you would
be the first 17 month i don't know that
we have any 17 months right now
nova yeah i'm your i mean number one
subs that's absolutely huge
yeah that's true all right well what
else can i do for you
just to be clear is the scale for the
caller rating uh to
six or yes exactly you're a five and a
half out of six that's exactly right oh
okay
yeah you're right um okay so that's a
serious question though so
um in terms of the supreme court if you
were a supreme court justice who was
disappointed
and you had some kind of like secret
radical agenda like
maybe amy coney barrett maybe not so
secret
um would you be would you
like go out of your way to make it seem
like you weren't
trying to rule in favor of a certain
agenda to like
make you have a better public image yeah
i would probably try to throw some bones
uh to try to make myself seem like a uh
you know a
a fair jurist i guess right
do you think uh do you think that's
going to happen with amy coney barrett
or
yeah i wouldn't be surprised i mean
we've seen it we saw it with john
roberts we saw it
with gorsuch and kavanaugh although
typically on different cases
yeah i mean sometimes we just call it
ruling correctly where you just you
can't be an ideologue on every single
case
right that's interesting yeah
i guess people aren't always you know
people do always care about their image
so that they don't
you know so that idea you know
ironically so they can push some kind of
agenda later
that is a that is a known strategy for
sure yeah
all right alex thank you so much i'm
gonna let you go i really appreciate the
call
jacob ball checked in with a really
strong 50
super chat and wants to know his super
chat rating uh you're an a plus plus
jacob you're one of our top super
chatters for sure
that's not at the exclusion of anybody
to be clear but
you are definitely a very very strong
super chatter let's take a couple of
other calls here
and see what's going on let's go to cam
from texas cam from texas you're on the
air
hello can you hear me yes i can awesome
okay
so on my uh um my question for you is uh
basically since the gop thinks that our
elections are you know
fraudulent what happens to their excuse
for when they want to invade other
sovereign countries
you know to spread democracy as they say
in other words according to them
even our elections are bogus so who are
we to go
and tell other countries how to do
elections basically like they want to
they want to they want to invade other
countries
to spread democracy and they don't even
believe in their own so
that's fair but what you have to
remember is they're total hypocrites i
mean again
they they claimed the presidential
election was fraudulent but they haven't
said anything about the senate or the
house so even within the same election
they're hypocrites
you're not going to get them with with
with other countries i mean
you're obviously completely right but
they're just complete hypocrites
i see yeah okay
all right no problem very good that was
a that was a quick one let's go next to
matilda from sweden matilda from sweden
you're on the air
matilda
matilda
matilda from sweden we can sort of hear
you
okay oh there you are yes how are you
yes i'm very good where in sweden are
you calling from
i i'm calling from uppsala really
it's called yeah i'm familiar with oops
north of stockholm right beautiful area
yeah it's really nice i like it now let
me ask you this
are you wearing a mask right now
no i'm wearing a uh
a scarf a scarf all right very nice yeah
well what's on your mind today matilda
yeah i was
thinking about um your political system
and your election system yes it's very
different from
us here in sweden and most places in
europe
indeed and i was
kind of wondering if
you ever think that that will change
like your
system with the electoral votes and and
stuff like that
well you know the thing about the system
is it benefits one party very much
republicans are have have won
multiple presidential elections because
of the electoral college system
so for as long as that's the case and as
long as republicans have some power
they will do their damnedest to make
sure it doesn't change
yes yeah i understand that but
i mean now they are raising all these
questions and it's almost like they're
questioning the electoral system i know
that's not what they
really are doing right but it sounds
like it
and well what's interesting about what
you're saying matilda is
if republicans uh want a real cut
and dry system where 40 000 votes in
pennsylvania wouldn't even be a
topic of discussion you go popular vote
right because
biden won by like 5 million if if we
just had a popular vote there would be
nothing to contest because obviously
you're not going to flip 5 million votes
but it's all just what argument can they
make
today that will help them it's not about
principles
yeah yes
that sounds really frustrating for for
you as a country
it is well only to some of us some
people like the system because it helps
them
yes but i think if you got rid of that
system you would have more parties
in in power as well that really depends
on that
that's not that's less clear that could
you know there's there'd be a couple
different ways to get more parties in
power one would be a proportional
representation system in the house of
representatives many european countries
have that
um also getting rid of you know putting
in some kind of ranked
choice voting or single transferable
vote would be another way to encourage
third party voting but i don't think
just
going electoral to popular for president
would do that necessarily
okay yeah
hello anything yeah well i'm here oh
yeah good
i thought you you you disappeared listen
matilda i have a question for you
in sweden are swedish meatballs simply
called meatballs
yeah got it right because exactly yeah
it's like
french fries are just fries in france
because it's france yeah exactly
yeah it's just meatballs it's just
meatballs beautiful
um all right well listen matilda i think
you're gonna get
very very high marks as a caller
oh thank you yeah i'm lucky that that
system
was just reinstated so well some people
call it luck some people call it skill
oh yeah thank you you're well you're
welcome uh great to hear from you though
in all seriousness
yeah i was really nice talking to you
too likewise and what kind of a dog do
you have i think is the last question
i have a yorkshire here yorkshire
terrier what i'm trying to think those
are little right
yeah though he's really little
yeah and they're not very um i don't
want to offend anybody in the chat but
jack russell terriers are kind of
insufferable from a from a
personality standpoint does the
yorkshire have a personality issue
yes it does
my dog oh no of course not no he doesn't
even bark
at all all right good oh yeah matilda uh
thank you so much for the call
thank you all right very good matilda
from sweden how about that guys i mean
just
very good phone etiquette in all senses
of the word
um all right let's go next
where are we going next this is this is
interesting let's go to
naughty from ethiopia first caller ever
from ethiopia you're on the air
naughty from ethiopia you're on the air
hello
yes you're on the air oh wow nice
how are you good how you doing doing
well doing well um
so my question to you is i think you've
brought this up previously as far as
what we do with the uh trump supporters
the 70
plus million that have voted for him
that don't seem to be leaving the
country anytime soon
right well where would they even go
right i mean it's like yeah
it's not clear where they would go to
uh-huh uh-huh
so what's i know previously you said you
you know haven't made up your mind as
far as
how to kind of restate them back into
a more proper mental state but i don't
know if you've got to the answer yet
no i mean listen you know the mass
deprogramming of cultists is really
difficult and you look at
jonestown and jim jones and that was
only 900 people or 1100 or something
like that
and um it it you know it couldn't
couldn't be done people were completely
sucked in so i don't know
at mass scale how you do it i do think
starting with younger people
education is a part of it media literacy
critical thinking
epistemology um we probably
uh i mean i i just it's just it's a
herculean task i don't know how you do
it
yeah yeah also my second question
is uh my friends were kind of discussing
uh
what trump's uh odds would be if there
was no coronavirus considering that
even more people voted for him this time
yeah 2016. oh listen
i think if there was no coronavirus
trump gets re-elected and if trump
handles coronavirus well
he gets re-elected yeah yeah it's kind
of odd that uh
you know anybody any sane person in his
position despite
like what his politics are it kind of
makes sense to handle it well because it
just seems like a gimme
to handle it well get the extra votes
and write close to re-election
look at what happened in new zealand
right i mean jacinda ardern just
sailing into re-election because she
handled the virus
well yeah exactly so are you ethiopian
yeah i'm actually ethiopian i live in
maryland yeah oh
you're calling from maryland not
ethiopia but i was born in ethiopia oh
that is deceptive is all hell
wow um very very interesting now listen
i want to ask you how long how old were
you when you left ethiopia
so i came uh when i was 10 years old i
was i actually came on my birthday and
due to time difference i celebrated my
birthday the day i left and then the day
i got here as well
that's amazing well listen let me ask
you i don't know how much you know about
this but
uh as i'm sure you know there is a uh a
jewish population in ethiopia sizable
compared to just about any other african
country other than maybe maybe south
africa
um is there within ethiopia
is there anti-semitism against ethiopian
jews
um not that i know of uh i haven't
come into contact in person with any
ethiopian jews no
from documentaries that i've signed i've
seen it's more so a
small population that kind of keeps to
themselves and a lot of them would like
to
you know kind of move to israel but
they're just kind of i guess waiting on
their visa
okay all right that's that's a very
specific
situation that you're pointing out for
for what is
you know an entire population of people
that is interesting though that that's
your understanding of it
yeah all right very good well uh
i appreciate the call first ethiopian
caller that i'm aware of but not from
ethiopia
yeah thanks for taking my call david you
have a good one all right my pleasure
very very good
uh okay let's let's talk to a couple of
other people
if we can um
how about uh how about jamie from
georgia jamie around there
moved to israel but they were just kind
of i guess waiting on their visas
okay all right that's a very jamie
all right very good jamie i appreciate
the call
first ethiopian caller that i'm aware of
but not from ethiopia
jamie last chance you got to turn that
off
jamie dear god
okay we were doing so well so well
until that happened let's go next to
casper
from tehran iran
hello david can you hear me yes i can
oh perfect so before
i ask my question i did want to uh thank
you
uh for dragging me out of the right-wing
pipeline
and uh this is the the an iranian
right-wing pipeline
uh no the i do consume a lot of amer
american media simply because i did live
in canada for a while oh okay i am into
iran right now you are i believe you i
believe you
yeah this is this is not me deceiving
you good but
uh my question to uh for you is uh we're
under the impression that biden will
return to the iran deal correct
i believe that he is going to try i mean
the thing is
iran would be rightfully skeptical
because what if the next
what if trump wins again in 2024 and
just cancels it again you know
well that's well that's actually part of
my question so
in in thinking that you know the next
republican administration is coming
yeah what is exactly stopping them from
tearing the deal
apart again like is there a way to make
it an official treaty with a country
to prevent them from doing that i
certainly yet the answer is yes but it
won't happen for exactly the
the reason that that makes it all the
more difficult to do
um so unfortunately with donald trump
just
canceling the deal even though iran
had had stuck to the terms of the deal
um it it if you're iran if
if i were iran i would be thinking wait
so we need
more because just to get back into the
same deal
that they just bailed on that doesn't
really make sense for us we'd rather
just keep
developing doing nuclear research
so i think it's going to be i think it's
going to be tough
but i am optimistic that it will be put
back together now i'm curious
would you prefer to be in a deal with
the us
and not do nuclear research or would you
just prefer
your your country to be doing the
nuclear development
honestly i would prefer the antagonism
between our two countries to decrease
significantly interesting is your sense
that that's the prevailing
position among your circle of people
among my circle of people and generally
in the more liberal quote-unquote
liberal areas of iran the major cities
of course
interesting i'm curious in in the
liberal circles in iran
are there lots of unwritten rules about
people not sticking to the official
rules of the country
uh well what do you mean by that you
tell me what what do you think of when i
ask that
like not sticking to the rules in the
country um
i would say the way i interpret it at
least
yes it is they have a basically like a
a secret life and a public life
essentially right
yeah and what would be what would be
some of the differences
between the private the secret and the
public life
oh well uh the things that are taboo
the things that you're not allowed to at
least show in public
that you do uh you know in your private
life in behind closed doors with your
friends or family
and is there risk is there is there risk
to that or is it basically understood
that
as long as you're private and sensible
you're going to be fine
oh it depends on where you live like i
said the more liberal liberal areas
in tehran there are more leeways that
you can get away with
the more conservative areas unlikely
interesting
very very interesting yeah and the
elections
yeah iranian elections are in about a
year i believe
so you did your part in getting trump
out your right wingers out
i'll do my part to get the least bad
option let's do
i that's that's exactly the the right
way to go i appreciate that you doing
that
and again david thank you my pleasure
great to hear from uh
wow that's quite quite a phone call
there all the way from iran i like it
uh all right let's go to
uh there's a lot of very interesting
people holding on here
let's see now everybody's claiming to be
iranian
in the in the uh names that's
interesting
let's go to matthias from mexico city
also known as
df matias you're on the air
yes you're on but garbled oh
uh let me try not using my headset let's
do it
thanks anthony by the way for the 100
super chat
furious with facebook i love it
um hello yeah that's that is much better
oh that's great uh so um i have a
strange question about uh biden
okay um you know i'm uh
i'm a trump uh hater sure uh
but uh i would call myself
something of a biden supporter or what i
mean is that i would want to imagine
that he's the best
person you know able for the job and so
on and obviously he's much
he's nothing compared to what trump got
up to every day
right but of course uh i saw
i saw this video that you've probably
talked about this before but i didn't
see it where he was
moving and touching some girls in a
like photo op uh session in the i don't
know i don't know what
it was but you're talking about trump
now right or who are you
you're talking about trump or biden now
no no i'm sorry i'm talking about uh
biden
oh i haven't seen that video are you are
you saying the video of the senator's
daughter who he hugged
come again there's a video where he's on
stage with a senator
and he hugs the senator's daughter i
think are you talking about that video
uh yeah i think i also saw that one but
there's there's
another one that i saw the other day
okay haven't seen it
i certainly can't confirm the existence
of it but uh but i'm
uh you're saying you saw it okay
yeah uh maybe maybe i can send you the
link through
chat or something right now but i saw it
on instagram actually and it was a
compilation
like uh it seemed i could find later a
longer video of the whole photo
where you know you couldn't actually
find anything wrong because it's only
right at very specific
specific moments that he does something
strange like he sniffs
uh a girl's hair all of the girl's hair
and then he's uh my my
uh friend who's here and i were agreeing
that that
you don't you don't touch uh you know a
girl even if you're
in a photo you know in the way
that very clearly biting was doing it
and like i was trying to say this
compilation where
it's only one minute long and you get
like the the
one after another the moment that when
he does it
it's quite shocking okay so did given
that i i've not seen at least some of
what you're describing did you have a
question about the video
well uh yeah like i started saying at
the beginning it's just
that i'm quite i'm obviously very
relieved
that trump is out and i'm
happy you know across the board with uh
biden being president yeah and i just
don't know
what to make of this video of this fact
that we got a sexual predator out of the
white house
you guys did it but
what comes next is a much better
sexual predator yeah i just don't think
that that's a fair comparison i mean
there's no question that biden's been
accused of sort of being
uh kind of cringy in certain situations
but
you know trump had a 13 year old accuse
him of rape right i mean we're talking
trump trump appears to be an actual
predator who hung out with jeffrey
epstein
and you know it's i i i don't know
you know what but no so we do what like
what i i'm just i'm just not sure where
to go with this you know
no yeah i agree completely that it's not
uh
it's okay to just get better
even if it's not perfect and there's no
there's no comparison like you said
yeah but uh yeah i don't know it was
uh i didn't have a question just
that video had me you know thinking
about
what do any
of these uh old politicians
uh behave properly or is it so
is the is the point of your call that
you think a lot of politicians
are drunk with power and behave
inappropriately or what
like what's the no no no
i don't know i don't know man i just
you're not sure uh
it seems like it it starts to feel
like pedophilia is incredibly prevalent
and we don't even know it but hold on a
second do you have anything linking
biden to pedophilia
look i wouldn't i wouldn't say that uh
biden is a full-on pedophile i i i know
he isn't
he's just these are some why i mean to
even mention that
this is like right with you know no
who's even
talking about that at the other other
than the the most absurd
it's now because now it's become to even
mention pedophilia is becoming an insane
stretch
so but what what are you saying i'm
saying
there's no evidence i've seen that would
make me utter the word pedophilia when
i'm talking about joe biden
okay yeah no but okay but what i was
saying before is that
uh i know he's not a pedophile he hasn't
raped
any ch and any children but you can
has he even been accused okay we got
that no
this is crazy we got to disconnect it's
it it's getting to a point where it's
irresponsible like i'm cringing
it's actually i'm like i'm that it's
it's it's
it would be irresponsible for me to
continue doing that uh because it's so
crazy
i'm not saying he's a pedophile it's
like what are we even talking about what
are we even talking about here
um wow that went completely off the
rails
um holy [ __ ]
all right let's see if we can just talk
to like one or two uh was that with it
did i wait
too long to cut it
what do you guys think or did i cut it
at the right time or too soon some
people might have wanted more of that i
don't know
it's like at a certain point i do have
to apply some
critical thinking and and you know some
responsibility it was
i waited too long to cut it that's fair
yeah that may be
uh okay let's go here to
uh where are we gonna go let's go to
kimmy from
finland kimmy from finland you're on the
air
hello hello hi uh
this is my first time actually trying so
i'm surprised you picked
up i'm as shocked as you are kimmy
well i had a question about
i guess the worst case scenario if the
democrats don't take back the senate
okay after um jenner so like
imagine there's no there's no further
stimulus
and so the democrats don't really get
anything done do you think
it's going to be basically a
duck presidency no i think no i don't
it's a very good question i listen in
the next two years if biden doesn't have
the senate
he's not getting tax reform done he's
not getting
uh health care you know public option
expansion
lower medicare age he's not he's just
not getting any of that stuff
but on day one uh joe biden can stop a
lot of the bleeding caused by donald
trump with a series of executive orders
he can repair to a great degree
hopefully the relationship
with china he can
do a lot in terms of environmental and
climate regulation via executive order
he can i mean i think you're right in
that we can't count on republicans
to be a part of any of this but i do
think that there's a lot that joe biden
can do and i think he'll do it during
his first hundred days
even without the senate but yes some of
the big things
aren't going to happen without the
senate yeah
so they'll basically act like during
obama
when he lost the money i think it was
the house of representatives
yes exactly that's exactly right
and so do you think who would then have
the
i guess the momentum going into the the
next midterms would that be
would the democrats be like on the back
foot or
yeah i mean 538 today put out a piece
saying that
republicans are now favored to take the
house in the midterms in 2022.
it's way too early to i just think you
could you know
four years ago we had no idea what this
year's election was going to look like
four years before that nobody would have
guessed trump would be the republican
nominee
i just think it's too early to say too
much at this point
yeah makes sense all right yeah
yeah well i think that clears up my uh
my question there um but yeah i'm i'm a
fan of your show and i've been watching
for a number of
years but uh thank you i'm a fan of
yours and i'm a fan of finland
great thank you all right thanks so much
very very good to hear from you
uh all right guys that's gonna do it for
me the event we were scheduled to
to see was actually canceled um and then
someone told me that it took they did it
two hours early for 15 minutes so that
it wasn't cancelled but we we
essentially just missed it
um so but whoa somehow we've got a
cooking show going now
i appreciate everybody who joined me i
will stream again hopefully tomorrow we
will hear either from president-elect
joe biden or from donald trump
it'd be great for trump to answer some
questions wouldn't it
i'll see everybody then